this is the first tax season after
college athletes have been allowed to
profit from their name image and
likeness but female athletes continue to
receive fewer sponsorship opportunities
and lower compensation for their from
their male peers one company has
announced it wants to help bring
awareness and level the playing field so
check this out
the recent announcement comes from the
tax preparation company h r block it
plans to provide one million dollars in
sponsorships and support for female
college athletes to bring more attention
to the need for equity in college sports
we're all going through the same things
right now and getting more people to
watch our games support us and i think
that's that's the biggest thing we're
fighting for and want to continue to to
push and bring more awareness to women
in college athletics h r blocks program
called a fair shot will also provide tax
preparation services to help sponsored
athletes navigate their changing
financial circumstances
it's been a little complicated for me
just because i've never dealt with the
business part of it but i have a lot of
people in my corner helping me out
including h r block
being the first to help me with my taxes
just showing me the pathway of what it's
like to become a businesswoman sophomore
caitlin clark a guard for the university
of iowa's women's basketball team and
zia cook a guard for the university of
south carolina's women's basketball team
are receiving the first two sponsorships
the nil rule change has opened up new
income streams for these college
athletes sometimes they don't know how
to navigate that and that's what h r
block is here to help with the company
also plans to amplify the voices of
female athletes and bring more awareness
to their individual sports for more
information go to hrblock.com
a fair shot